can we just pause on that just for me
from like a human factors perspective
and also an ai perspective
what's how difficult uh so there's like
when there's two people there's also a
third person that's
the ai part there's some level of
automation like autopilot maybe
that's correct maybe you can kind of
talk about the psychology of like
you said making decisions really quick
80 percent
how do you deal with another brain
working with you
and then also the automation is there
interesting
interplay that you get to learn and also
as that change throughout your career i
imagine it got
gotten better in terms of the automation
or perhaps not
well i can tell you so that let's say
there's a bunch of stars no this is this
is good this is good and this is
i'm enjoying this because now we
actually get to talk about something
other than a tic tac so
um so let's start with the a6 the a6 was
really an analog airplane
uh that was built in the 60s all right
and
there's been studies done on the crew
coordination which is the interaction
between the pilot and the bombardier
navigator
so we would fly low at night in the
mountains so
i was stationed up in whidbey island
washington so you've got the cascades
and
incredible amount of time and we would
get in the simulators because unlike
normally people think terrain following
and there's the radar is the 111 the b1
has a system like this but it'll
the radar can see and it'll fly
basically flies a straight line so it
goes up and over mountains and back down
and up and over mountains where the a6
was really manual so you do this low
level routes where you're gonna you're
gonna fly in the mountains at night
you're gonna be at
you know 500 to a thousand feet above
the ground ripping through like
fog layers because you don't need to see
outside you're you're literally flying
on a little tv screen and a radar what
are you looking at most of the time so
just as a screen
it's this really primitive if you look
at it now what we did you'd think wow
that was crazy
but it was really fun so is it similar
to like the flair stuff
is that is no are you is it this thing
is totally radar-based now the airplane
had a
ball it's a target recognition and
multi-sensor it's called a tram
um so you're looking at like basically
like
dots of hard objects no actually what it
is is the the bombardier navigator had a
radar and he was getting raw feed off of
a pulse radar
in front okay so it's just basically
mapping the mountain so
if you look at a mountain on a radar and
you're coming up on it the front side is
going to be
it's going to give you a really bright
return and on the back side it's just
going to be a giant shadow
because you can't see on the other side
so the bombardier navigators would do
that and we they would have charts and
they could
shade their charts knowing that hey if
we turn a little bit left here we can
get in this valley we can sneak up this
valley and then go around the back side
of the mountain
which is what the airplane would do and
it's inside to interrupt
i'm going to just keep asking dumb
questions i apologize but the pilot
can can you at a high level say what the
pilot does versus the bombing
bombardier uh so you're you're actually
just control
i'm i'm flying the jet i have the
throttles the stick and i have a uh
it's about a probably a four
inch or six inch wide by maybe
four inches five inches high it looks
like it's literally a crt
that's how old it is a crt screen and
what it would do what the radar would do
is
the the the bombardier navigator is
looking at his radar and he's looking
out about 12 and a half miles in front
of the airplane
so he has the range really scoped down
because the radar can see a lot further
he's looking at about 12 and a half
miles when we're in the terrain mode
where we're dodging mountains and stuff
and what the pilot has is there's
they're called range bins and there's
eight of them
so the very far range bin is the 12 and
a half mile
you know and the closest range been it's
a thing and it'll be like between like a
half a mile
and or a quarter mile to three quarters
of a mile the next one might be three
quarters of a mile to two miles
and then it just keeps going out like
that so if there's a mountain for let's
say we're on a flat plain
and there's a mountain out in the
distance at 15 miles and we we're just
driving right at it
so when we get to the point where it
hits 12 and a half miles where the radar
is going to see it on his scope
my 12th my range bin for that would pop
up and it would show like a big bump
like a mountain
and then as i got closer to it the next
arrangement would pop up and show it
and i could see that that bump was
moving towards me and then if i turned a
little bit
you know to go over here i'd see the
mountain go over to the right hand side
and i could do that but it wasn't like a
a video game it was it's literally like
if you think of the original ataris yeah
but you build up i
imagine that you start to get uh a
really deep sense
of like the actual 3d environment
based on that little atari's it's solid
you're exactly right and you have to
you have to train so there's been
studies a matter of fact a lot of the
basis
and people probably argue with me but
it's true there were studies done
watching asics crews in our simulators
we called it the wist
the weapon systems trainer and it was
not even a motion it just kind of sat
there and
you just you could fly these things they
had terrain that they would inject into
the system
but the crew coordination so you get so
my first
uh my first fleet bombardier navigator
who
who i'll name him his name is crusado uh
he's uh works at apple uh pretty high up
bro mit grad i think computer
engineering
he's scary smart so chris could really
work and matter of fact all the guys
that flew us so there's another guy matt
who also worked at apple who's now at
sap we did our first night traps
together
the bond between us i mean it's one of
those things that you just you're never
going to forget but chris and i when we
started flying together we were actually
the most junior crew
in the squadron uh we'd spent a lot of
time training and
and and chris was amazing at how he
could work the system
uh one because he was extremely
brilliant and he was
had that inquisitive mind of oh we could
do all these different things and
there's all these
degradation modes but we spent a lot of
time
to see how good we could actually get
because and it's
you you almost talk in partials so as
the bn is looking at his radar scope
chris would say i've got rising terrain
that's just what they say
showing rising terrain at 12 miles and
i'd see the little bump and i'd say got
it
this is going to go to your question on
the autonomy and how you work with two
heads yes
so when you first get together the
interaction it's
it's it's almost like you have to
rehearse it you have to know
and you talk in full sentences the more
and more
we fly together chris could go
i'm showing and he'd get like rising out
and before he finished i'd say i've got
it
so you end up starting to talk in
partials because
i have to trust him like
i mean there can be no i can have no
doubt that he knows how to do his job
because i'm literally looking at this
little scope that's not giving me this
continuous picture of that mountain
moving remember the mountains here
and then it's going to pop up here and
then it's going to pop up here because
there's gaps in the coverage on how the
system was set up remember it's an
analog system
to where he is telling me like i can't
see all the way to the left and he
he's got a wider scope on the radar but
my screen doesn't show that
so he's telling me start a left turn how
to avoid a hard turn
you know and we would do that so my
channel this is all happening quick
very quick well you're doing we we would
typically fly between 420 and 480 knots
of brown miles an hour uh well 427 miles
a minute
okay between seven and eight miles a
minute is what you're flying as fast
at night i mean i broke out of clouds i
mean i remember him and i flying
we're on it's the ir it's called an ir
route uh an instrument route that's
low they're all around the country
there's ir344 that we used to fly which
would
coast in off of or you'd fly from the
land you go out over the ocean turn
around and then you could practice
actually coming in on a coastline
and we were flying and we ended up in
the clouds
keep in mind we're between 500 and a
thousand feet in the mountains and we're
in the clouds like you can't see
anything
and i had to turn off our red lights
that flash you know they're called the
anti-collision lights
because it was reflecting off the clouds
and it starts to bother you just gets
annoying so i turned it off and we
we're flying we're flying we're flying
we break out of that coastal marine
layer
and poof we break out and it's it's a
decent night and this is right by mount
st helens this is kind of where we're
coming in so we're coming in from the
east and we're just north of mount st
helens is where the route goes
and you look up you know because you can
kind of see the silhouette of this
mountain that's right next to you but
you're flying along you're just like you
know you got to trust
and you can see houses you can see the
lights they're above you we're literally
below people's houses flying down these
valleys and stuff so just
incredible experience so when you take
that and then you move into
an f-18f so now we're into modern
technology that was actually built in
this century
uh uh and you're flying so now you know
the wizzo is behind us and we're not
doing those night low levels but that
same type of crew coordination
that has to happen because what you're
doing is
you're sharing the load so most of the
communications that go out of the
airplane the wizzo does all the talk and
he's got actually he uses
that's the weapon systems operator in
the back of an f-18f
so he's going to run uh well the radar
kind of runs itself now
but we have a situational awareness
display and it's it's linked to all the
other areas just
curiosity what's the situational
awareness display because that term
comes up a lot
think of it as uh think of it as a god's
eye view so if you have a
the back of the super hornet has well
the block twos has about an eight by ten
display for the wizzos
um that they can look at the pilots is
smaller it's down between us it's a six
by six between his legs and they're
they're getting ready to redesign that
boeing is but
when you look it'd be like if you put
your airplane and you're looking down
so all the stuff like if your radar
seeing bad guys out in front of you be
like looking down going oh i'm right
here and now there's bad guys out here
and my wingman is over here and it shows
everything it's just like
it gives you you can look at that
display and go oh okay
i can see where everything's at i can
see if one guy's trying to target
another guy
it shows you all this it's an incredible
amount of knowledge that comes up
for the crews to maintain uh
the the overall picture of what's going
on
because it's happening so fast and this
is that autonomy piece this is the third
brain
so we're all looking at it and the third
brain is doing fusion
it's pulling stuff together going oh
this is all this guy this is this guy
this this guy it's sending it out
through the link so all the airplanes
are talking to each other through this
digital network
you know that we don't even see it just
says that airplane says hey i'm over
here and it tells us and we go he's
right there
and then we can go he's his airplane
says oh i'm looking at this airplane
this bad guy and it shows us oh he's
he's over there and he's looking at this
guy i mean it's an incredible
amount of visual intake because your eye
you can hear a lot but when you look
down at stuff it's so you know you can
solve the picture
really quick the third brain is doing
the
sensor fusion uh the integration of the
different sensors and gives you a big
picture view
what about the control like is there and
i apologize
as if this is a dumb question but you
know people use the high level term of
autopilot
how much is there let's use a
loose term of ai how much automation is
there how much ai is there in
helping you control there um the ai
piece would be more of a control loop
because the digital flight controls so
the airplane actually
they had to make the airplane easier to
fly and when i say easy it's relative
because people go i could do it because
i did it on flight sim
it's real life is a lot different in
flight sim you have no apparent fear of
death you'll do things in
simulator that you would never do in
real life but uh
the the autonomy in the airplane to
allow you to manage
i mean because you think about it you've
got a radar that's feeding you data
you've got a targeting pod that's
feeding you data all that stuff is
hooked to your head
because you've got a joint helmet
mounted queuing system on that it
basically maps the magnetic field in the
cockpit so it can tell where your heads
at looking
so if i turn my head to the right the
radar will actually look to the right
the targeting flare will look to the
right
and oh by the way the backseater has a
helmet on too so he can look to the left
and he can do things so depending on
what sensor he's controlling
so if he's got control of the targeting
pod and he looks left the targeting pod
looks
left but if i have something where i
want to lock a guy up that i don't see
that maybe the radar didn't see but i
can get over and now point the radar you
know get the because it's a it's a phase
array radar now it doesn't really
scan there's all kinds of cool stuff
that uh
that technology uh brings because if you
just if you went back
30 years and said hey or 40 years ago
and said hey we're gonna have this
helmet and you're gonna be able to slew
everything to your head
and i don't mean a mechanical setup but
i mean literally you're just gonna map
magnetic resonance and go oh look and
then i can i can literally slew my
sensors this fast
and then mash a button and transfer you
know
high quality coordinates from a system
into a joint
you know jadam which is a joint direct
attack munition that is the gps bombs
that you see all the time
and then let that thing fly and i'm i'm
solving this problem in
seconds by minutes or hey i got it we're
gonna have to menstruate coordinates and
you
you know you bring back the data and
then they do all the targeting for and
then they send another group out to get
it
instead of all that now it's that fast
so there's a
okay i mean we probably don't have
enough time to talk about the beautiful
fusion of mines that happens when two
people are flying
controlling the plane but at a high
level this is a really interesting
question
for people who don't know what they're
talking about like me
which is what is the difference between
a human being
and an ai system like what
can what is the ceiling of a current
ai technology for controlling the plane
like how much
does the human contribute is it possible
to have
automated flight for example like what
is
the hardest part about flying
that a human does expertly that an ai
system cannot
in warfare situations in in
flying a fighter jet line so i would say
ai systems are usually black and white
when you write the algorithm for an ai
system
it's it's it's it's really it's
basically you're taking
thought and turning it into a giant math
problem is really what you're doing
right so you've got this logical math
problem math problems are
there's there's there's a line it says i
can or i can't and it's a it's a very
finite line
you know but you can go up to the line
where a human
we all have gray areas where we go
maybe yeah i'll try it um so humans can
operate within that gray so if you took
if you take an airplane and say
and i'll just take a hornet for a while
a super horn it doesn't matter any
airplane
and you go here is the flight
performance model of the airplane so if
you know what an
uh an em diagram is the energy so it
basically says
the airplane can fly as slow as this it
can go as fast as this it can pull this
many
g's force of gravity you know so one two
three four five six seven
and then based on the airfoil design and
everything else and how it can pull
here's how it's gonna fly you know
because it's really physics based
well if you depending on how you write
the ai but typically ai you don't want
the airplane to leave controlled flight
right you want to maintain it so that it
is flying in a controlled envelope
where there are times and you can go
back to world war one
where people intentionally departed the
airplane from controlled flight in order
to obtain an advantage which is that's
where the human goes
can i do this i know it's outside of
where i would normally go
but i can do that so you can do some
crazy things now especially since the
flight control logic
in modern airplanes with digital flight
controls
they're extremely forgiving so you can
literally i've done things in super
hornets that
literally even as a pilot inside the
airplane you're just like wow i cannot
believe it just did that
like it'll flop ends which defies most
logic and i guess
you know in a way you could probably
program it but i still think that when
you get to the edges
that may or may not give you an
advantage
there are things that a human can will
do
that ai won't and i don't think we've
got to the point because
how do you how do you map illogical
solutions
you know most ai is logical it's based
on some type of premise when you write
the algorithm to control
it there's bounds
you